so just a bit of review what happened
from 2000 to 2004
so from 2000 and actually i should
really say from 2000 to 2006 because
that really was when the housing bubble
happened
well financing got easier so financing
easier
financing
got easier or they essentially they
lowered their standards
and it got progressively easier and
easier and easier every year we went so
then that allowed
more people
more people
to bid on homes
so it increased the demand artificially
in in certain ways because we saw from
that new york times article that
people's income for an increasing and
the population wasn't increasing
anywhere near as fast to soak up the
supply so all it did is allow people to
uh who were renting before and who
couldn't save the money for the down
payment now to participate so now you
had more people bidding for the same
house
to bid up houses
to bid up houses
but that led to the obvious question
why did financing
get easier and easier
so let's go back to the good old days
like the early 90s and and or actually
let's go even before that let's go to
kind of the classic you know
what what happens to get a housing loan
well traditionally if i wanted to go
alone get a loan i would go to my bank
i would go to my bank
and that loan officer at the bank
he's going to be giving the banks money
for your house right like he's going you
he gives you money and you're going to
pay him interest
right this is me
and so that loan officer at the bank he
really cares that they're not going to
lose money on the transaction if he's
going to give you a million dollars he
wants to make sure that no matter what
happens if you lose your job if you get
arrested if you skip town that he's
still going to be able to get his
million dollars back and if you go back
to our our equity and balance sheet
presentations that's why back in the day
they made sure that you put 20 25 down
payment on your house that you had a
good credit rating that you had a good
steady income because that that banker
that loan officer was going to be in
trouble and his bonus was based on how
good the loans he gave held up so that
was the traditional model
what happened that was started to happen
in the mid 90s especially in california
and then nationwide in about 2001 2002
is you had what we call a securitization
of the mortgage market and and this
in all fairness this actually happened a
while before with things like fannie mae
and freddie mac and i'll do a completely
separate video on those but fannie mae
and freddie mac essentially had the same
standards they had the standards of we
call them conforming loans that you know
you had i think the number you have to
have 20 down you have to have a certain
credit score
certain steady income so fannie mae and
freddie mac were these entities that
might buy the loan
from your local banker but their
standards were just as high as the local
bankers and they were based
there i think they were actually
you know they had oversight by congress
so they they had a there
they weren't giving away loans for free
but i'll do a whole other presentation
on fannie mae freddie mac
but what you had happen in the late 90s
and especially in the early part of this
decade is you had a whole industry
outside of the government-sponsored
entities the government-sponsored
entities are freddie mac fannie mae and
freddie mac
and this is essentially
instead of you going to your local bank
for a loan
this is me again
i would go to my local mortgage broker
countrywide is the most famous of them
i think they're cfc that's their taxes
stock ticker they're not bankrupt yet so
i would go to countrywide
and essentially you know i would get
a million dollars from them a home loan
i would get a million dollars from them
and i'd agreed to pay interest to
countrywide
but then countrywide would do this like
a million times so times a million right
they'll do they'll give home loans to a
million people put them all together and
then they'll sell the loans they'll sell
the loans to like let's say bear stearns
so that's an investment bank let's call
it bear stearns
hope none of these people sue me i guess
they have bigger troubles now than
wondering about my youtube videos
they sell to bear stearns and then bear
stearns will package a bunch of these
mortgages together essentially ious from
people
and then they would sell those to
investors right they would sell these to
an investor so essentially instead of
instead of country wide
ascent being responsible for my loan the
lo my payments now go to these investors
and you could watch the
that says investors i know my
penmanship's horrible but you should
watch the videos on mortgage-backed
securities and collateralize debt
obligations if you want to get
understand a better understanding of
exactly how the money flows go but the
bottom line is because of this process
what's happening
countrywide is just kind of just being a
transaction transactional they're just
doing the paperwork for my loan they're
temporarily holding the loan and and and
and they're doing a little bit of duel
diligence and in return for that my that
that countrywide mortgage broker
will get you know we'll just get a fixed
fee for for doing that transaction maybe
they'll get like five thousand dollars
for just doing the paperwork for my
mortgage right
and then bear stearns will package a
bunch of these mortgages up and you know
now it's going to be in the billions
and uh and and then you know repackage
them and sell them to investors and the
process bears turns gets a cut and you
know bearcats are doing this for
millions of mortgages at a time so maybe
bears turns it's in you know it's in the
billions of dollars that bear stearns
gets a cut so bearish trends essentially
just gets a fee
like the mortgage broker of course it'll
it's it's a huge fee and then the
investors are going to get my interest
payments
right and let's say if the interest
rates if i'm paying seven percent of the
other million people are paying seven
percent the investors are going to get
seven percent on their money
and that seems like a pretty reasonable
proposition and you know of course the
investors would care that that the money
that they're essentially giving because
they're giving money to the investment
bankers we're giving money to
countrywide and that's where my million
dollars is essentially coming from
the only reason why the investors would
give their money is if they have a lot
of confidence that
these are really really good loans
well the investors they don't know who i
am they don't know what my job is how
likely i am to pay the loan so the
investors have to rely on someone to
tell them that these are good loans and
that's where the ratings the rating
agencies come
ratings
ratings agencies
and these are standard and poors and
moody's and and they rate these these
assets these these these mortgage-backed
securities and what they say is well
they'll look at this big you know
package of mortgages these million
mortgages that bear stearns is patched
together and they'll look at the
historical default rate and they'll say
well you know these these mortgages
really haven't been defaulting and you
can think about why they haven't because
housing price has been going up so these
mortgages really haven't been defaulting
there's a very high chance you're going
to be able to get all your money back so
we're going to give these what they call
you know let's say they say triple a
rating
so this investor
who knows it could be the central bank
of china it could be a hedge fund it
could be a whole set of people it might
be the investment banks themselves
sometimes they actually bought these
just to make some extra money
these investors they don't know who
actually borrowed the money or what kind
of credit rating they had or anything
but they just took a leap of faith they
said well standard and poor's or moody's
did the work they're telling me that
this is aaa
aaa which means the highest level of
debt or you know whatever they told them
maybe it was single a or i forget all
the the different qualities of debt but
they just took their word for it
and they got their seven percent
interest on their money whatever it was
six percent money and that worked out
pretty well
and this
and so these guys they like the fact
that they were getting the seven percent
they said this is a good asset class so
then they they funneled even more money
so then there were even more investors
there are even more investors that want
to do this they're like this is great
this is like you know with very little
risk i'm getting a pretty good return on
their money that's better than putting
in the bank that's better than buying
treasury bills right so then even more
money flowed in
well more money wanted to invest in
people's mortgages but countrywide would
say well we're already giving mortgages
to all of the people who qualify so in
order to actually find more people who
want mortgages from us we'll just have
to lower the standards a little bit
right and we can lower the standards
because we find even when we do lower
the standards no one's defaulting on
their mortgages and i'll in the next
video i'll maybe give a little bit more
color why so countrywide will issue even
more mortgages and give them to these
investors with even lower standards and
of course countrywide the mortgage
brokers countrywide they love it because
every time they do a transaction they
just get some money and then they give
the mortgage to the investment banker
which packages them up and then sells
them to investors so they get it off of
you know their hands and they just got
the fee so they just collect big cash
the investment banks love it right they
just love doing the transactions because
they get more and more money every time
they do the transactions and for the
moment the investors seem pretty happy
because they keep giving money into this
system so to speak even though you know
they might be reading the newspaper and
seeing that the standards are going down
but they're consistently getting their
return
and because the defaults were very low
over this time period and i'll explain
in the next video why the defaults were
very low
they felt that they they were they were
getting a good return maybe six or seven
percent on investments that had very
very low risk
so in the next video i'll explain why
uh the defaults were very low in that
time period see you soon